I just made a decorative floating shelf for
my bedroom, and a matching shelf for my wife.
But these ones aren’t just for looks.
Slide a couple knick knacks into just the
right positions, and you’ll discover there’s
quite a bit more to them, than meets the eye.
Concealment shelves, aren’t a new idea, But rather than spending hundreds of dollars
to get one myself,
I wanted to see if I could create a “Stealthy” design of my own. And here’s what I came up with.
These “Stealth Shelves” are high quality
pieces of furniture that’ll compliment your
home decor, but will also hide a spare set
of keys, passports, or any spare cash, you
might not want the general household knowing
about.
If your kids need a break from phones and
video games, a secret shelf like this is a
great way to make those devices, virtually
disappear in just an instant.
The secret to the “Stealth Shelf” design,
is a pattern of powerful magnetic locks hidden on the inside.
Set a few choice decorations in exactly the
right places, and the secret compartment clicks
open, giving instant access to sweets, treats,
or even defensive firearms the moment you need them.
You can find magnetic locks these at any local
hardware store, sold as child safety locks for kid-proofing your cupboards.
And I’ll put a link to where you can get
them in the description.
Now the shelf is still a shelf, and works
great for showcasing pictures, or displaying random trinkets.
And can handle a good amount of weight because
it screws directly into the studs in your wall.
You can customize the shelf with any feature
you want, or stay on the simple side and build
a basic version for as little as $35.
Keep an eye out for my next video because
I’m going to show you step-by-step, how to make your own.
I designed mine so when the secret compartment
drops open, a little motion activated LED
turns on, lighting up the interior, like a
display case.
But this detachable light also doubles as
an instant flashlight, in case the power goes out,
and can help locate dangerous intruders
in the dark.
The back of the light is magnetized as well,
so it clicks right back into position when
you’re done, and automatically shuts off
15 seconds later.
Now despite how easy it is for you to open,
it’s very unlikely that thieves or kids
will find their way in, and here’s why.
By studying the shelf from the outside, there’re
really no obvious feature that’ll give it
away as a secret safe in the first place.
And since we made it ourselves, we’re the
only ones that know the secret magnetic combination.
Not to mention if you use multiple locks in
multiple locations, it’ll make cracking
the code exponentially trickier.
Well now you know how beautiful and functional
decorations like these, can also serve as
stealthy storage containers.
To keep important items out of sight and out
of mind, but still give quick and easy asses
to them, the moment they’re needed.
So go ahead and try making a “Stealth Shelf”
for yourself, and revel in the satisfaction
you’ll get from the secret power and security,
you’ve got hidden inside.
Well that’s it for now.  If you liked this project, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com